notre commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ne peut être que sensible alors
revitalisation du plan qui avait
disparue depuis une quinzaine d'années
et chacun peut s'accorder sur l'intérêt
de soutenir la réflexion prospective
pour éclairer les choix de notre pays
alors que nous faisons régulièrement et
collectivement
le constat d'un manque de vision
stratégique à long terme de l'état sur
les sujets entrant dans le champ des
compétences de notre commission
l'objectif de cette audition est donc
double d'une part nous permettre de
mieux comprendre vos objectifs au delà
de ce que précise les textes parus au
journal officiel du 2 septembre et du 4
septembre 2020 comment monsieur le
commissaire comptez-vous mettre votre
expérience au service du pays
comment vous envisagé de travailler avec
les membres du gouvernement d'autre part
nous souhaitions échanger avec vous sur
des thèmes qui nous sont chères et qui
entre dans le champ de compétence de
notre commission
par exemple je pense aux grandes
politiques de réseaux d'infrastructure
qui contribue à l'aménagement de notre
territoire dans le secteur portuaire du
transport de fret et de la logistique
par exemple nous manquons d'une vision à
long terme alors que la république
populaire de chine en bise ambitionne de
déployer ces nouvelles routes de la soie
sur 30 à 40 ans je pense aussi aux voies
et moyens que nous permettront d'assurer
la cohésion et l équilibre de notre
territoire alors que les fractures
territoriales peine à se résorber à se
résorber dans la mobilité dans l'accès
aux soins est globalement dans l'accès
aux services en proximité des forces
contraires sont à l'oeuvre entre la
métropolisation qui demeure puissante et
l'aspiration d'une part croissante de
nos concitoyens à vivre dans les petites
et moyennes villes et à la campagne
dans le même temps l'état est passé d'un
rôle d'aménageur actif un rôle de
facilitateur et d'accompagnateurs qui se
matérialise par un changement de
vocabulaire
le programme d'attractivité du
territoire et est remplacé par la
politique d'égalité des territoires est
maintenant de cohésion des territoires
qui s'est matérialisé à travers la
création de l' agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires là une cité par
la loi du 22 juillet 2019 examinée au
fond par notre commission et dont notre
collègue louis jean de nicolay était le
rapporteur
comment percevez-vous ces changements et
quelle orientation pourrait être soutenu
selon vous je pense enfin bien sûr à la
transition écologique qui est un enjeu
majeur pour notre indépendance nationale
à terme votre audition intervient à un
moment important car le sénat examinera
à bientôt
le projet de loi portant lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et renforcement
de la résilience face à ces effets qui
est issu des travaux de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat il en place par
le président de la république après le
grand débat national et le mouvement des
gilet jaune au delà des règles que le
législateur peut créer pour assurer le
respect par la france de ses objectifs
en matière de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre j'ai souhaité que
le commissaire recueillir vos analyses
sur deux points d'abord concernant les
relocalisations industrielles qui sont
un puissant levier car elles permettent
à la fois de lutter contre les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre à porter en
france de prévenir les roses l'érosion
de la biodiversité
comment l'état les collectivités aussi
l'accompagner au mieux ce mouvement
selon vous est également assuré son
acceptabilité sociale dans certains cas
second point le financement de notre
transition écologique
la dernière note que vous avez publié
propose d'isoler la dette de guerre de
la crise sanitaire et de la relance pour
assurer sa soutenabilité et nous
permettent de continuer à investir
ce qui est particulièrement nécessaire à
la des corbeaux notion de notre économie
vous avez fait des propositions
ambitieuses pour la relance au delà des
investissements à réaliser
investissement considérable pour l'état
les collectivités des entreprises
quel rôle pourrait jouer et jouer la
fiscalité environnementale et
l'épargnent pour inciter la transition
selon vous comment assurer la transition
écologique dans un objectif de justice
sociale selon vous voici monsieur le
commissaire quelques questions et
suggestions que je vous soumets que je
soumets à votre appréciation
je vous laisse la parole pour un propos
introductif à l'issue duquel mes
collègues nous interrogerons merci
monsieur le commissaire encore une
nouvelle fois pour votre présence
si je recule j'ai le droit d'enlever le
mas qui a personne à 3 m merci de votre
accueil monsieur le président vous me
permettrez un sourire il ya si longtemps
que je ne me suis pas exprimé dans cet
hémicycle certains souvenirs sont encore
assez et vif donc je suis très heureux
de me retrouver là et de me retrouver
avec un certain nombre d'entre vous que
je connais depuis longtemps
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir invité
je ne prétendrai pas monsieur le
président que j'ai la réponse à toutes
les questions que vous avez posé car si
je l'avais j'imagine que le que le
statut de cette audition serait
différent mais nous sommes tous devant
des nécessités des nécessités que pour
un certain nombre d'entre elles
nous n'avions pas prévu ou pire encore
que nous avions élu dé au fil des
décennies et quelques-uns d'entre vous
qui ont partagé les combats politiques
qui ont été les miens se souviendront
que on avait essayé de mettre au premier
plan des préoccupations de la nation un
certain nombre de ces circonstances de
ces causes qui ont conduit à la crise
que nous avons rencontrés là parce que
cette crise a été pour la nation une
prise de conscience douloureuse
pas seulement du point de vue sanitaire
on pourrait naturellement rappeler que
des avertissements avaient été articulé
à propos même d'une possible crise
sanitaire
le livre blanc de la défense en 2008
avait été précisément le risque que
représentait que pourrait représenter
une épidémie de cet ordre et cette
affirmation n'avait pas été suivi je
n'en fait grief à à aucun des
gouvernements successifs
ou plutôt il faudrait en faire grief est
ou ce qui revient au même pas été suivi
des décisions et de la mise en place
d'organisations capable de faire face à
une épidémie de cet ordre mais grave
encore la nation a découvert ses
faiblesses d'élus blesse structurelles
qui ont amené à des événements
absolument inédit et qui ont surpris
tout le monde le la pénurie de
médicaments et sur une très large gamme
alors le sénat avait fait naturellement
à un rapport sur ces sur ces sujets là
encore le l'accumulation de rapports
tout ce travail est pertinent et qui
servent en réalité
à occuper les rayons des bibliothèques
une fois qu'ils ont été produits
ce qui est une souffrance pour vous qui
est qu'il est produisait mais ce qu'est
pour la nation une pièce incroyable et
les commissions parlementaires et le
conseil économique et social avec qui
j'ai beaucoup travaillé pendant ces six
mois et les think tanks divers et variés
tout cela ne débouche pas souvent sur
grand chose et on l'a vu avec ces
pénuries là on l'a vu avec d'autres
faiblesses sur lesquels j'essaierai de
revenir dans une seconde et donc s'est
imposé à un certain nombre d'esprits moi
je me battais pour ce sujet depuis très
très longtemps sans jamais imaginer que
quand j'en aurai la charge s'est imposé
un certain nombre d'esprits notamment
président de la république l'idée que en
effet le long terme devait être
réenraciner marche pas s'ils devaient
être ré enraciné dans le débat public
français
vous avez fait allusion monsieur le
président à la chine
j'ai souvent écrit que la chine
gouverner à 30 ans et nous parfois même
pas 30 jours
parce que la pression de l'actualité des
événements des chaînes de télévision
continue de l'éruption des sujets que
vous connaissez temps avec des
spécialistes ou des pseudo spécialistes
autoproclamés qui font flamber des
débats qui ne sont pas des débats sur
lesquels on prend la peine de réfléchir
pendant un certain temps et de fixer des
horizons lointains et donc
ces horizons de 30 ans moi je dis 10 20
30 ans les les trois étapes qui sont au
fond l'étape d'une un horizon assez
proche pour être perçue et d'un horizon
de génération c'est trois étapes là nous
avons le devoir de les ressaisir alors
je veux vous dire dans quel cadre
j'essaie de réfléchir et avec qui j'ai
c'est de réfléchir le cadre le cadre
dans lequel j'essaie de réfléchir c'est
celui du projet de société que la france
a construit et porter pour elle-même et
face au monde
et si on part du projet de société alors
un certain nombre de nécessité vont
apparaître et qui forment pour moi le
cadre de la réflexion
[Musique]
nous avons le contrat social le plus
généreux du monde
je crois que on peut le soutenir sans
avoir l'air d'être du côté des
superlatifs mal passé le contrat social
le plus généreux du monde la volonté de
solidarité la plus affirmée et de
l'école à la santé la solidarité face au
chômage
on peut le prouver sur chacun des
domaines de l'action publique mais je
veux dire une chose qui fait le vont le
plus profond de ce que je pensais de ce
que j'essaie de porter je ne vois pas
qui peut s'inscrire en faux ce contrat
social est impossible à soutenir si nous
n'avons pas l'appareil productif capable
de le financer
or cette préoccupation au travers des
années s'est étiolé et c'est pour ainsi
dire effacés 2 la volonté ou de
l'élaboration de la volonté de l'état
pourquoi parce que c'était un sel et peu
à peu l'idée que vont céder sujet dans
l'état n'avait pas tellement à s'occuper
que c'était le domaine le lot la
compétence et la légitimité des
entreprises et des grandes entreprises
que c'était les logiques économiques
interprétée par les acteurs de
l'économie et par les personnes morales
qui font l'économie qui devait prendre
les grandes décisions et ses grandes
décisions nous ont amenés à une
situation qui pour moi est absolument
paradoxal est insupportable voilà que
nous sommes un pays capable des plus
grands exploits technologiques et
scientifiques
nous savons produire des satellites nous
savons produire des fusées pour les
mettre en orbite
nous savons produire des avions parmi
les meilleurs du monde
nous savons permettait aux pyrénées je
suis de le rappeler nous savons
construire les hélicoptères et les
moteurs d'hélicoptères qui sont les
meilleurs du monde
nous savons construire des sous-marins
nucléaires qui installe dans dans un
seul tube à la fois une ville une base
de lancement de fusées une centrale
nucléaire
nous savons construire des automobiles
nous avons été une nation de pharmaciens
très en avance nous deux médecins nous
avons été très en avance et nous sommes
incapables d'assurer et de défendre
notre place sur des secteurs de
production absolument centraux nous
avons un déficit commercial de la nation
qui selon la manière de conter se
situera autour de 75 milliards par an et
vous savez bien que l'allemagne est à
200 milliards d'excédents
cette année on comptera 65 milliards
mais si on compte le transport ça fait
80 2 milliards et demi de déficit
commercial la place de l'industrie dans
le pib de la nation est tombé à 12%
et encore les 2 25% en allemagne mais
elle est de 10 9% en italie et elles
mêmes de 16% en espagne
et nous sommes en déficit commercial
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne naturellement
mais nous sommes en déficit commercial
vis-à-vis de l'italie et vis-à-vis de
l'espagne
aussi est ce paradoxe incroyable de voir
un pays capable de faire face aux défis
scientifiques et technologiques les plus
importants que le 21e siècle propose et
nous sommes incapables d'être présent
dans des secteurs aussi simple
enfin simple aussi exigeant et
méprisable que les biens d'équipement
nous avons 33 milliards de déficit du
commerce extérieur sur les biens
d'équipement
je parle pas de l'énergie savent pétrole
il est pas chez nous je l'entends mais
nous avons une capacité électronucléaire
qui méritent d'être rappelés et spa doc
cela rend le projet français selon un le
projet social français dont nous savons
tous ce qui le choque du sentiment
national ou de l'unité nationale rend ce
projet insoutenable sur le long terme
peut-être je me trompe mais je ne vois
pas qui peut défendre le point de vue
contraire et ceci voilà pourquoi c'est
très important que votre commission
existe qu'elles soient spécialisés
autour des sujets qui en font le
le socle et ceci dans un temps qui est
un temps de très grande mutation qui ont
été encore accélérée par l'épidémie très
grande mutation qui ont été accélérés
par l'épidémie selon moi en aménagement
du territoire je trouve cela heureux je
pense que ce que l'épidémie a rendu
présent à l'esprit d'un très grand
nombre de nos concitoyens c'est que ce
que vous avez appelé la métropolisation
monsieur le président c'est à dire la
concentration des activités humaines et
des et des modes de vie danse des unités
urbaines de plus en plus concentrée et
qu'attend de plus en plus l'énergie et
l'activité de la société
cette métropolisation en raison de
l'épidémie elle s'est trouvée mise en
cause dans beaucoup d'esprits et tout
d'un coup beaucoup de nos concitoyens
ont découvert que peut-être il pouvait
imaginer d'autres modes de vie que ce
qui leur était imposé par cette
métropolisation
ce qui veut dire aussi que sacré pour
nous beaucoup d'entre nous sont ont été
élus locaux ça crée des obligations des
exigences et des défis qui sont tout à
fait essentielle des défis 2 je ne
dirais pas aménagement du territoire
mais de réaménagement du territoire et
vous avez parlé de des questions que ça
pose en termes de mobilité que ça pose
en termes de réseau que ce ceci est tout
à fait important prenons simplement un
fait
le télétravail
était il y a un an jour pour jour une
perspective lointaine
[Musique]
douze mois après le début de l'épidémie
le télétravail est devenu un mode de
presque normal classique d'exercice d'un
certain nombre des tâches de la société
économique d'éducation culturelle
politique le distant ciel comme vous
dites est devenu familier même à ceux
qui ne l'avaient jamais approché ou
n'envisage ait jamais de l'approcher
évidemment ça pose la question des
réseaux et la question de 2 de la
numérisation croissante de la société
avec ses atouts et ses handicaps et
beaucoup d'entre vous sont élus
municipaux départementaux tous vous êtes
dans le plan de l'installation de
réseaux de fibre ou bien
est ce que on passe par des réseaux
cuivre ce qu'on passe sous par les ondes
est-ce qu'on passe par la fibre et des
notions aussi exigeante que le ftth sont
devenue familière à beaucoup d'entre
nous geslin le privilège d'être
responsable d'une communauté
d'agglomération dans laquelle en tout
cas dans sa partie agglomérée la
puissance publique a fait à apporter la
fibre à tous les foyers à toutes les
adresses et à tous les sièges
d'entreprises sur investissement public
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous en
recevant les dividendes et c'est une
opération qui a été lancé il ya 20 ans
et en voilà à quel point la pensée du
long terme doit être réintégré dans la
réflexion qui est la nôtre et c'est la
même chose pour le développement durable
pour la question climatique
les deux sujets sont d'ailleurs
étroitement liés je suis sûr que quand
on a créé la commission à votre
commission monsieur le président avec
ces deux sujets certains rangs ont vu
une addition un peu artificiel en
réalité c'est le même sujet parce que au
fond c'est la sujet c'est le sujet de la
recherche d'un équilibre pour le présent
et pour l'avenir et pour l'avenir de
long terme et l'humanité sens bien d'une
magna et l'humanité occidentales en
particulier sent bien que d'une manière
ou d'une autre si elle ne répond pas à
la question de cet équilibre là c'est sa
survie même qui se trouve menacée
et c'est ce dont vous avez la charge
alors on voit bien quels sont les
grandes lignes je parle maintenant du
volet écologique et climatique
moi j'en distinguerait 3 si vous voulez
bien
la première c'est la question proprement
climatique qui doit dans ses priorités m
en première ligne la question des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
de la production d'énergie au regard des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et de
ce point de vue là on va bien les très
grandes mutations qui sont en jeu j'ai
j'ai reçu la présidente du haut conseil
pour le climat qui a la chance ou la
particularité d'être présente au conseil
sur le président et le haut conseil sur
le climat en france et d'être au sein du
haut conseil sur le climat britannique
en raison de son origine canadienne à
l'aller 2 les deux capacités et au fond
si on lille et papier très important qui
sortent sur ceux sur ces sujets ce qu'on
retient c'est que le grand mouvement qui
doit être initié qui est en cours
c'est l'électrification du parc
automobile le premier et
l'électrification du chauffage
des logements ces présents à peu près
dans tous les papiers mais la question
est est ce que notre production
d'électricité est en l'état capable de
faire face à ces exigences la à ces
mutations là à combien peut-on estimer
[Musique]
l'augmentation nécessaire de la
production d'électricité je vais risque
un chiffre alors ne m'en veuillez pas si
je me trompe
après tout ça fait longtemps que la
nation aurait dû se saisir dans son
ensemble de cette préoccupation donc si
l'on regarde retour du chauffage
électrique dans les logements et
d'électrification de du parc automobile
à ce moment là on se trouve devant
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
augmentation nécessaire de 35 % de la
consommation électrique sans émissions
de gaz à effet de serre j'ai déjà dit je
veux le répéter devant vous je le dis
avec humilité mais avec certitude je ne
vois pas comment on peut assumer cette
exigence de production supplémentaires
et demandé en même temps qu'on renonce à
la production d'électricité nucléaire en
france
je ne sais pas dire je veux bien prendre
en compte tous les tous les arguments
mais le la question de l'éolien
elle se heurte à
interrogation l'une sur le bilan carbone
et l'autre sur l'acceptabilité sociale
de la multiplication d'éoliennes sur la
terre ferme offshore
c'est naturellement autre chose et la
question du photovoltaïque qui est une
piste à coup sûr intéressante jean marc
jancovici est venu devant vous je crois
devant votre commission pour expliquer
que la question du photovoltaïque
c'était la question de la production des
cellules photovoltaïques et elle demande
une quantité d'énergie considérable pour
pour simplifier faire fondre le silicium
pour faire des cellules photovoltaïques
et si vous faites fondre du silicium
avec des centrales à charbon
vous ne remboursez jamais les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre vous ne
compenseraient jamais les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et donc vous voyez
que ça ouvre des questions qui tout
débouche sur la production d'électricité
sans compter que dans la préoccupation
de l'appareil productif que je défende
est devant vous à l'instant j'ai
conscience d'être sur ces sujets
minoritaire sur bien des points mais je
je défends en conscience ce que je pense
et ce qui me paraît ressortir des
chiffres et des études je vous ai je
suis naturellement prêt à entendre
toutes les objections mais si je prends
ça rend compte faut aussi rappeler que
la france tenait dans le secteur
électronucléaire une place de premier
rang mondial et le cea
son on a là des capacités très
importante d'autant que si on va vers la
volonté de favoriser des des productions
d'énergies alternatives ce qui est la
décision de la nation de que vous avez
voté que le que le gouvernement a
avalisé
alors on sait avec certitude qu'il va
falloir mettre au point
inventer des gestion de réseau pour
intégrer l'électricité produite police
entré à la dimension de de nos villages
de nos centrales photovoltaïques sur des
terrains vagues des des couvertures de
parking et de grands magasins des des
ombrelles photovoltaïques sur des
hectares et des hectares
il faut inventer le réseau qui
permettent d'intégrer et de délivrer
pour utiliser un mot franglais que je
n'aime pas sûr sur chacun de nos points
de consommation est menée en parallèle
la question de la réflexion sur
l'économie de consommation le ce que
l'association négawatt fait depuis
longtemps et à juste titre toute cette
réflexion là doit être intégrée et elle
peut être intégré en se débarrassant si
possible des obsessions a priori parce
que il ya qu une certitude c'est que le
mix va obliger à rassembler le mix
énergétique va obliger à rassembler des
modes de production différents et donc
des modes de gestion de réseaux
différents
et ce sont de très très grands
investissements monsieur le président
comme vous l'avez dit pour l'instant pas
à l'échelle deuxièmement j'ai dit
premièrement les gaz à effets de la
limitation des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre deuxièmement la biodiversité
que nous voyons bien menacée
troisièmement le refus de
l'artificialisation des sols et si j'ose
dire
l'amélioration de la qualité agronomique
des sols
parce que tout le monde voit bien qu'en
matière de production agricole sur
laquelle nous nous sommes fait doubler
par l'allemagne par les pays-bas la
france n'est plus aujourd'hui que le
troisième exportateur de dans le domaine
agricole et agroalimentaire derrière
l'allemagne et des pays bas
ce qui pour un certain nombre d'entre
nous si profondément attaché à
l'agriculture est comme une blessure
si l'on veut concilier les productions
de plus en plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et de la vie animale et
la capacité productive
alors va falloir faire des bonds de
géant dans la recherche et dans la
technologie de des modes de production
respectueux de l'environnement ceci nous
ouvre des champs considérable ouvre à la
france deschamps considérable
et monsieur le président si je suis je
et j'en finirai la 6e place devant vous
devant nous ce que nous sommes tous au
même poids devant des problèmes aussi
exigeant si je place devant nous ces
questions des grandes mutations d'exiger
par le réaménagement du territoire par
le la préoccupation climatique par le
respect de notre environnement naturel
et le besoin de reconquérir l'appareil
productif dans des secteurs dont nous
sommes absents j'ai une note en bas de
page ici jouer un petit 1 et note en bas
de page
je ne confonds pas la relance et la
reconquête la relance nécessaire elle
s'adresse où elle vise à soutenir des
secteurs de production existant la
reconquête pour moi c'est la volonté de
la nation de reconstruire des secteurs
de production dont nous avons disparu et
c'est pas tout à fait le même sujet et
donc le les remarques qui sont faites
ici ou là sur
et qui tendent à mélanger les deux pour
moi ne sont pas ce que je vise donc je
disais si l'on met toutes ses
obligations devant nous alors on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya un besoin
d'investissements absolument
considérable on pourrait en dire autant
des réseaux ferroviaires on pourrait en
dire autant des réseaux électriques on
pourrait en dire autant des réseaux
numériques qui on pourrait en dire
autant de deux delà de la recherche de
partenaires industriels
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
soutenu dans la note que vous évoquiez
l'idée de même si le mot est inadaptée
mais c'est pour faire image d'un plan
marshall qui fait suite aux dépenses de
guerre qu'il a fallu faire contre le
virus
cette articulation là elle ressemble à
une articulation historique qu'on a
connu la guerre et la reconstruction la
guerre et la reconquête et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense qu'il faut
que nous réfléchissions à réserver à une
action aussi importante des sommes
considérables rendu aujourd'hui
accessible par les conditions du crédit
créé par les grandes banques centrales
rendu aujourd'hui accessible
combien ça durera ceci est une autre
question je crois que ça durera un peu
en tout cas suffisamment si nous ne
faisons pas ça si nous n'avons pas cette
idée
c'est une vision de citoyens
on a des débats mais si nous n'avons pas
cette idée de l'exigence de la
reconquête
de l'appareil productif dans les
conditions qu exige la prise de
conscience du temps sur le réaménagement
du territoire et sur la défense des
impératifs écologiques
alors je pense que nous avons les plus
grand risque de voir s'effondrer le
projet national français voilà la vision
dans laquelle je me trouve dernier mot
avec qui le faire alors j'ai déjà
commencé un travail approfondi avec le
conseil économique et social qui va
entrer dans une période nouvelle de son
existence et avec les commissions
parlementaires
donc avec vous je n'ai aucune espèce de
prétention à quelques monopole que ce
soit nous sommes là pour enraciner des
idées oublié depuis longtemps dans le
débat public
et si les citoyens s'en saisissent alors
les gouvernants s'en saisiront parce que
c'est dans ce sens que ça marche
c'est l'opinion publique et qui est au
fond le gouvernement du peuple par le
peuple pour le peuple comme dit notre
constitution n'a jamais été autant
d'actualité que dans ces temps de
démocratie médiatique et donc c'est avec
vous que nous devons si vous l'acceptez
prendre l'habitude d'un travail
construit et durable pour précisément
fléché avoir tous les débats nécessaires
on peut être en désaccord complet avec
ce que je dis je ne vois pas comment on
peut l'être mais peut-être peut-on
l'être jeu
en tout cas je sais que notre modèle
français est au risque il l'est depuis
longtemps mais maintenant on le sait
vous souvenez que valérie disait après
la guerre de 14 notre civilisation
savons aujourd'hui que nous sommes
mortels mais c'est le modèle français
qui se trouvent en péril parce que on a
été pendant longtemps c'est pas
négligent ou un peu éloigné des
nécessités que j'évoquais la voilà
pourquoi je suis non seulement à votre
disposition mais déterminé à travailler
avec vous pour prendre toutes les
richesses de réflexion que vous avez sur
ces sujets depuis longtemps ils soient
illustrés par des études nombreuses mais
pour les mettre en activité pour que les
ces mines la soie à nouveau mise en
exploitation en tout cas ça me paraît
une nécessité pour pour les moments que
nous vivons et que nous allons vivre
dans la décennie qui vient
merci beaucoup si monsieur le haut
commissaire vous nous avait conviés a
effectivement travaillé avec vous parce
que je ne prends pas de risques au nom
des membres de la commission pour vous
dire qu'effectivement nous sommes à
votre disposition et que nous avons bien
l'intention de travailler avec vous
parce que je crois que vous avez évoqué
un sujet important vous avez
effectivement paris relancer reconquête
et relancerait conquête et bien c'est
pas
c'est pas une nuance de c'est une nuance
de taille parce qu'il ya bien la balance
aujourd'hui mais demain comment on fait
pour reconquérir et je crois que vous
pouvez compter sur nous sur l'expérience
des élus locaux que nous avons été et
puis aussi sur l'expérience de vivre sur
le terrain régulièrement et de
représenter nos territoires
merci on a beaucoup de demandes de
parole y en a 10 alors je vais donner la
parole à une série de 5 et plus fameuse
série de cinq
madame st pée merci monsieur le
président monsieur le haut commissaire
cher françois bayrou je veux pour ma
part vous questionnez sur votre
positionnement toujours dans le cadre du
réaménagement du territoire et de la
reconquête des territoires sur les
liaisons ferroviaires
vous avez déclaré récemment dans un
journal local
nous avons bâti un réseau ferré fondée
sur le principe de la grande vitesse et
nous avons oublié en chemin les réseaux
de proximité
il est absolument scandaleux déclariez
vous que la ligne entre bayonne et pau
ne permettent pas des transports facile
rapide et ponctuelle entre ces deux
villes sans remettre en cause nullement
l'intérêt de cette proposition est ce
que vous sous-entendez qu'il faille
renoncer à une prolongation de la lgv
jusqu'à hendaye et pau et à l'échelle
nationale pensez vous que les lgv ne
sont plus une priorité et qu'il faille
se concentrait sur les petites lignes
c'est ma première question ma deuxième
question quid sinon des trains de nuit
plus précisément pensez vous qu'un train
de nuit desservons pau puis en die par
toulouse et seulement en haute saison
c'est à dire en saison estivale comme
c'est envisagé pour le moment par la
sncf
pensez vous que ce schéma soit
satisfaisant pour les
pyrénées-atlantiques je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et dans la parole
à monsieur marchand
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
haut commissaire en cette semaine un peu
particulière ou devrions être les uns
les autres dans les travées dans les
allées du salon de l'agriculture
vous avez évoqué effectivement le modèle
agricole français
et on voit bien que la crise sanitaire
le dérèglement climatique la
biodiversité mise en péril la précarité
alimentaire font aujourd'hui de
l'alimentation le sujet central
d'ailleurs c'est un sujet dont vous êtes
saisis dans une note du 18 décembre sur
la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire je cite il est assez
effarant de constater que nous sommes
devenus dépendants dans le domaine des
fruits et légumes à cause de nos
importations notamment de fruits
exotiques ou de jus de fruits
notre commission et vous souhaitez que
nous puissions travailler ensemble je
reçois bien volontiers cet appel notre
commission avec nos collègues des
affaires économiques nous sommes saisis
de cette question de l'alimentation
durable et local
à l'aune de la route et riocreux
territorialisation de l'alimentation et
de l'aménagement du territoire et nous
partageons d'ailleurs avec le conseil
économique social et environnemental les
mêmes préoccupations nous les avons
auditionné sur la nécessité d'avoir de
véritables politiques publiques qui
semble aujourd'hui par trop cloisonnée
et de développer des systèmes
territoriaux à l'échelle des bassins de
vie
est ce que vous partagez cette analyse
pour faire en sorte que demain nous
puissions avoir un plan marshall à
l'échelle d'un territoire pour cette
territorialisation d'activités
économiques permettant une alimentation
durable et local pour toute notre
population merci merci chers collègues
et d'un apparat la collecte des demies
on entendait la salle mais voilà
monsieur le commissaire nous sommes bien
sûr dans la commission de qui traite des
thématiques de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
et merci d'avoir soulignant leur propos
introductif le fait que ces deux
thématiques étaient bien sûr extrêmement
liés et lectrices sanitaires que nous
traversons le démontrent à l'évidence
néanmoins le conseil économique et
social environnemental auquel vous avez
fait allusion considère en tout cas j'ai
cru le lire que dans vos différentes
note celle du 28 octobre celle de
décembre et de février les thématiques
environnementales étaient insuffisamment
travailler ou explicitées et ma première
question est donc la suivante
envisagez-vous de faire une nouvelle
note spécifique traitant des
problématiques environnementales et à
défaut que répondez vous donc à cette
pseudo critiques du conseil économique
et social et environnemental
la deuxième question concerne le mode
opératoire que vous allez utiliser car
traiter d'enjeux économiques
environnementaux éducatifs culturels
nécessite bien sûr un dialogue
extrêmement étroits entre l'état et les
territoires vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos le souhait de l'échangé avec le
céser d'échanger avec les commissions
parlementaires
mais allez vous privilégier une strate
bien particulière notamment une strate
territoriale bien particulière pour être
connecté à la réalité donc des besoins
des territoires et surtout pour assurer
une transparence quant aux choix
politiques qui seront prôné voilà les
deux questions je voulais vous poser
monsieur le haut commissaire en vous
saluant et en disant je suis très
heureux de retrouver au sénat merci je
vais donner la parole à madame varia ce
oui monsieur le commissaire aujourd'hui
la crise sanitaire que nous venons de
vivre que nous vivons depuis un an
au-delà du fait qu'elle nous invite à
réfléchir à relocaliser la production de
nos médicaments et de notre matériel
médical
télescope il faut le dire des
difficultés de long terme que
rencontrent nos territoires ruraux
fragilisé par la réforme territoriale et
la concurrence a été dit des métropoles
sur le plan démographique un solde
naturel négatif qui n'est pas compensée
par le solde migratoire des effectifs
scolaires en baisse vieillissement de la
population et des services publics en
berne comme beaucoup d'autres
départements ruraux le mien la dordogne
qui est un des plus beaux départements
de france souffre d'une désertification
médicale qui nous fait craindre mais
vraiment craindre des difficultés
croissantes d'accès aux soins 0,8
médecins pour 1000 habitants
et dans la moitié va atteindre l'âge de
la retraite
nous savons que cette désertification
médicale ne sera pas compensée avant de
nombreuses années par la suppression du
numerus clausus qui ne met pas
d'ailleurs fin aux quotas de formation
dans les universités les élus locaux que
nous sommes commune
le pci département seuls et ensemble
d'ailleurs un font preuve d'initiative
et d'investissements colossaux pour
maintenir
enfin avec les moyens qu'ils ont autant
que pour maintenir autant que faire se
peut l'attractivité de ces territoires
du numérique financer certes avec l'aide
de l'état mais avec un apport très
importante du département et des
collectivités en passant par le
financement d'une nouvelle d'une navette
ferroviaire la création de maisons de
santé des bourses aux étudiants d aide
financière aux étudiants en médecine
pour essayer de les garder à
l'agriculture aux circuits courts à la
création de zones d'activités l'aide au
sport à la culture nos élus et nous
faisons preuve d'un engagement qui
mérite d'être soulignée dans la tâche
est très compliquée la crise sanitaire
semble réhabiliter notre ruralité parce
qu'il se trouve que notre ruralité ses
grands espaces
il se trouve que nous constatons en ce
moment de l'arrivée de deux néo ruraux
qui
vienne qui nous contactent qui veulent
installer de l'agriculture biologique ou
autre comment compter comptez vous
monsieur bayrou prendre en compte toutes
ces problématiques et convaincre qu'une
nouvelle politique d'aménagement du
théâtre du territoire équilibré est
nécessaire pour prendre en compte ces
inégalités territoriales criante sur le
territoire responsable il faut bien le
dire du sentiment d'abandon ressenti par
la population et faut le dire aussi
qu'ils par voie de conséquence se
traduit par une augmentation importante
à la fois du vote abstentionnisme mais
du vote extrême aussi très remarquable
sur nous sur nos départements enfin ne
pensez vous pas que l'état doit garder
la main sur ce que nous nommons nos
biens communs à savoir la santé
précisément le transport l'énergie a
fortiori dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
merci je vais donner la parole à marc
tadié idrac pierre médevielle et on aura
terminé cette première série de
questions et nous commissaire pourra
répondre merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le haut commissaire
votre récente note sur les secteurs
stratégiques pointe l'importance du
secteur de l'énergie le développement
des énergies renouvelables le couple est
à la réduction de la part du nucléaire
dans notre production énergétique
suscite de nombreuses interrogations
les énergies renouvelables dont
l'empreinte environnementale n'est pas
encore tout à fait évaluer sont en vive
croissance même si leur intermittence
pose la question de la décarbonation de
notre mix énergétique la question vous
l'avez compris sous jacente est
évidemment celle de notre indépendance
énergétique vous l'avez d'ailleurs en
partie évoqué dans vos propos liminaire
la france dispose d'ailleurs d'un
véritable avantage comparatif de ce
point de vue vis-à-vis de ses voisins
européens
ces productions énergétiques est
d'ailleurs l'un des angles morts des
travaux de la convention citoyenne nous
avons pu le constater lorsque nous les
avons interrogés ici alors que ce
secteur est primordial pour notre
réussite dans la transition écologique
monsieur le haut commissaire je souhaite
vous interroger sur le développement des
énergies et plus particulièrement des
énergies renouvelables et plus
particulièrement celle des panneaux
photovoltaïques que vous avez également
évoqué tout à l'heure dans un récent
rapport publié par le ministère de la
transition écologique
différentes pistes sont identifiées pour
améliorer leur bilan environnemental
d'après le rapport la relocalisation
d'un grand nombre d'activités et la clé
premièrement il convient de créer des
filières à haute valeur ajoutée de
recyclage les 50000 à 60 mille tonnes de
panneaux mis sur le marché en france
chaque année sachant qu'ils deviendront
des déchets d'ici 20 à 30 ans le rapport
préconise également l'ouverture de mines
en france le cas échéant avec des
soutiens publics afin de privilégier une
production nationale de matières
premières et secondaire que ce soit du
silicium indium argent et d'autres
matériaux qui serait plus responsable
pour que de la production importée enfin
le rapport préconise de développer une
vision de filières afin de relocaliser
la fabrication des panneaux notamment
des cellules
quel regard portez vous sur ces
recommandations le photovoltaïque
pourrait-il constitué un des axes
importants de la réindustrialisation
française quand on sait que 70 % de
l'empreinte de la france est composée
des missions importés et que la
réindustrialisation de notre pays
constitue un levier de diminution de
notre empreinte environnementale je vous
remercie
dernier intervenant pour cette série
question monsieur mais deviennent
monsieur le haut commissaire vous avez
ras pauliste faculté sa capacité de la
france à faire des satellites de
diffuser cette faculté à être le
meilleur angle certaines technologies
mais face à la relance ne pensez vous
pas qu'il va falloir faire preuve
d'humilité et preuve de capacités
d'adaptation c'est quand même nous
sommes devant un mur et il va falloir
vraiment s'adapter
vous avez rappelé les malheurs de notre
culture nous sommes plus que troisième
pays exportateur et depuis 2010 9
nous sommes devenus pays importateurs
nous ne produisons plus que nous
consommons jusqu'à mars est inquiétant
quand on connaît le potentiel serait
culture qui était la première lecture
européenne en agriculture il ya la
viticulture vous avez parlé de domaines
d'excellence français et c'est un
domaine c'est toujours un domaine
d'excellence
cette viticulture je pense que là aussi
on nous ont eu dans notre long bienne a
la prétention de moins travaillé que les
autres d'en tirer des conséquences
aujourd'hui dans viticulture il ya cet
acharnement qui vont peut-être d'une
certaine arrogance parce que nous sommes
peut être les meilleurs nous nous
pensons le meilleur a refusé un
étiquetage standard qui se fait dans
tous les pays et nous disparaissions des
rayons de certains magasins scandinaves
ou anglo saxon il suffit de regarder je
crois la tête d'un acheteur la pomme par
exemple dans une bouteille du jurançon
d'irouléguy c'est pas très parlant
l'étiquetage et je pense qu'on ne
gagnerait avec cette humidité ses
facultés d'adaptation et ont conservé
des parts de marché que nous sommes en
train de perdre bêtement et justement
à paroles
que voilà une large gamme de questions
essayer de répondre avec l'humilité à
laquelle monsieur médevielle nous nous
invite tous à denise saint-pé alors les
questions locales je vais aller très
vite encore que j'y sois naturellement
comme comme maire de pau très très
attachés comme ancien président du
conseil général des pyrénées atlantiques
[Musique]
la question des lignes ferroviaires
paraît si on en reste dans le cadre
actuel de la réflexion difficilement ce
soluble actuellement les lignes
ferroviaires secondaires je lisais une
étude indique enfin qui indiquait que le
kilomètre passager coûte à chaque région
un euro à sa g 1 km 1 euros des régions
moi je crois que on doit laisser la
porte ouverte ou favoriser l'ouverture à
des mutations technologiques
par exemple à du matériel roulant léger
on a le matériel
on connaît bien le matériel roulant
actuelle et ce qu'il coûte ce qui le met
je pense que on peut de ce point de vue
gagner beaucoup avec une mutation du
matériel roulant les lignes que vous
évoquez
et que nous connaissons bien ces lignes
là elles vont très rapide et un grand
nombre de lits qui ne sont pas
électrifiés vont très rapidement se
trouver devant la question de du
matériel roulant hydrogène on est en
train de développer aujourd'hui le le
premier train à hydrogène les droits
gêne et horn n'étant pas autre chose que
un mode de stockage de l'électricité
mains d'un mode de stockage de
l'électricité sans inconvénient sens
sans rejet sans pollution encore
insuffisant du point de vue de la
capacité énergétique mais très
performants du point de vue écologique
comme vous le savez mieux que personne
nous avons construit à pau la première
ligne de bus à haut niveau de service à
hydrogène au monde
et comme vous savez elle marche très
bien la question c'est la production
d'électricité j'y reviendrai dans les
interrogations suivantes
mais je pense que on à la lune une
réflexion à conduire sur ces toutes
petites lignes de mutation du matériel
vous savez que des idées sont avancées
matériel ferroviaire léger ou bien
transformation des lignes en des ans des
voies qui seront
ouverte à des trams mettons des trams
bus quelque chose qui pourra permettre
les liaisons sans avoir le poids
d'investissement que représente la
remise en état d'une ligne ferroviaire
et vous savez bien accueilli je pensais
c'était évidemment très très exigeante
pour nous tous
est-ce qu'il faut renoncer aux lgv
pourtant non on a vous voyez bien on a
il s'agit de l'alimentation principale
d'un réseau qui doit ensuite se diffuser
alors sur la palombe plus je vous
répondrais d'autre que la palombe bleue
c'est le train de nuire qui existait
entre paris et pau et tarbes et qui voit
aujourd'hui en haute saison un projet
qui passe par toulouse vient beaucoup
d'interrogations sur ce poids et pour ma
part je serai circonspect si vous voulez
bien
monsieur marchons avec les masses comme
un homme a du mal à repérer l'exigence
de re localisation de production
agricole avec des conduites agronomique
bio ou le plus haut possible
ça développe absolument partout ça va se
développer absolument partout on vient
de dans notre communauté d'agglomération
vient de lancer cette opération la
communauté d'agglomération achètent des
terres agricoles les met à la
disposition que de ce qu évoqué madame
vayas 2
néo ruraux décider à produire bio en
maraîchage et nous leur achetons la
production avec la cuisine centrale qui
qui fait les repas circuits courts
garantie de prix et aide réelle et nous
recevons à peu près chaque semaine des
visites d'autres communautés
d'agglomération de communes intéressées
par le par le processus que nous avons
mis que nous avons été les premiers à
mettre en place tant que je suis
absolument certain que cette que cette
que ces modes de production locaux
durable durable locaux est en effet une
perspective importante
vous voyez bien ce que tout ça veut dire
si on réfléchit c'est que ça ne peut pas
être des actions individuelles où ça ne
peut que très rarement être des actions
individuelles
on redécouvre y compris dans le monde
agricole la vertu du collectif et du
collectif partagé entre les agriculteurs
ou les petits groupes aux sociétés
d'agriculteurs et la puissance publique
et ceci va avec la politique de refus
darty field artificialisation des sols
et toute la réflexion quant aux cadres
dont je ressens la nécessité c'est le
réinvestissement du pont entre
puissances publiques et acteurs
individuels qu'ils soient entreprises ou
individus et c'est vrai dans la
reconquête productive
j'en dirai un mot probablement dans le
courant des questions
stéphane demi bon je souriais en vous
entendant parce que les les trois notes
d'ouverture en compte en produire entre
une et deux par mois avec la toute
petite équipe qui est la nôtre je veux
rappeler que nous sommes en tout huit
équivalents temps plein pour le plan de
la nation mais moi j'ai toujours plus
aux petites équipes certain nombre
d'entre vous le savent bien et donc de
ce point de vue là je ne me plains pas
mais en effet les trois sujets que nous
avons posées sur la table se prêtait peu
à une réflexion écologique ou plus
exactement étaient traités par exemple
dans la première note la première note
c'est fait et si le coc vite durée on
est en octobre
à l'époque tout le monde pense que ça va
finir mais nous il nous a paru
intéressant on avait des navets des
petits indices comme ça qu'ils qui nous
frappe et il nous a paru intéressant de
de poser cette question là c'est la
première note
c'est la première note stratégique qui
était en europe consacrée à ce sujet là
et si le coc vite durée la deuxième note
c'est les pénuries les pénuries de
médicaments et les secteurs stratégiques
comment sauvegarder ce que tout à
l'heure
l'un d'entre vous disait notre
indépendance la question de notre
indépendance et de notre indépendance au
moment de crise comment fait-on pour ne
pas être à la merci de rupture
d'approvisionnement qui dans une société
aussi développé que la nôtre ou
prétendument se développer que la nôtre
sont proprement inacceptable et la 3ème
note c'était la dette la dette du que
vides et éventuellement de la relance on
voit bien que
il faut il faut traiter jacques sujet
mais je ne perds jamais de vue la
question au sens large de la défense de
notre patrimoine environnemental et de
sa pas seulement sa protection et sa
réhabilitation dans l'avenir je pense à
la qualité agronomique des sols
c'est une politique autant de protection
que de réhabilitation et qui peut aller
très vite donc assez c'est la conviction
qui est la mienne
donc alors ensuite la strate
territoriales il vous étonnera pas qu'à
titre personnel je considère que le
labyrinthe territoriale est une des
faiblesses actuellement de l'action
publique mais c'est votre boulot dont je
vais pas le faire à votre place donc
c'est votre responsabilité au sénat en
particulier de réfléchir à ce sujet est
plus difficile encore que de réfléchir à
ce sujet de vous mettre d'accord sur ce
sujet parce que en tout cas la
complexification croissante à laquelle
nous tous élus locaux sommes exposés pas
seulement à albert ou ou à pau ce par
tous est une faiblesse nationale
d'aujourd'hui et il m'arrive parfois
d'envié napoléon dans sa dans sa
capacité de simplification de la vision
de l'action publique n'en sommes pas
tout à fait là donc tout le travail que
vous ferez je le lirai avec attention et
je le soutiendrai avec ardeur dans sa
territoriales je pense que le travail
qui a été fait sur les communautés de
communes et d'agglomération est un
travail extrêmement utile
c'est probablement le plus utile qui a
été fait au travers du de ces dernières
années il ya là au bord des bassins de
vie des bassins d'action publique mais
qui demande naturellement être ré
harmonisées avec les régions vous
étonnera pas que je pense que certaines
régions sont démesurés et donc
illisibles dans leur périmètre
[Musique]
et si je m'interroge note politique si
je m'interroge sur les raisons qui ont
fait qu'on les a découpé comme ça alors
je suis d'autant plus perplexe
donc voilà l'asra territoriales qui me
paraît la mieux adaptée
aujourd'hui dans la réalité où nous
sommes avec des impératifs de
réaménagement du territoire que
j'évoquais et de défense de notre
patrimoine environnemental
il me paraît que le réseau des
communautés de communes et
d'agglomération est un réseau utile
voilà mais c'est pour risquer une
réponse à madame maria la
désertification médicale est le résultat
d'une politique publique criminelle qui
s'est développé au travers du temps j'ai
même écrit un livre sur ce sujet que
j'ai pas publier pour des raisons vous
voulez pas qu'on connaît le sentiment
qu'ils avaient et se livre ce s'appelait
un crime parce que la régulation de
l'information médicale a été voulu
sciemment voulue et avec la complicité
de tous les acteurs y compris des
médecins eux-mêmes et des organisations
de médecins eux mêmes
c'est une ce pour moi c'est une des plus
nuisibles décision qui a été prise au
travers du temps alors naturellement
elle s'accompagnait aussi de mutation
sociologique très importante sur la
conception du travail des horaires de
travail sur sur la manière dont les
familles de médecins s'organisait la
place des femmes dans le monde médical
le mais il demeure que c'est un crime et
qu'en effet il va falloir durée c'est un
scandale est un crime pour le pays qui
se considérait comme le grand prix
médicale au monde et qu'il était qu'il
était donc je suis très profondément
d'accord avec vous et sur le travail que
vous faites aussi que les collectivités
locales font
conseils généraux en l'occurrence
j'imagine que c'est à cela quand ordonne
vous faites allusion
vous avez acheté votre réflexion sur
l'état dans sa légitimité de défenseurs
des biens communs et je partage ce
sentiment je voudrais répéter ce que je
disais à la réponse l'une des réponses
précédentes l'état désormais on dit état
stratège pour l'opposer à l'état
spectateurs que nous avons été pendant
30 ans 20 ans au travers de toutes les
alternances moi je pense que l'état doit
être fédérateur il doit être générateur
de tous les acteurs y compris des
acteurs privés on ne peut pas demander à
un acteur privé que ce soit un individu
ou une personne morale une entreprise on
peut pas lui demander de ne pas se
préoccuper de ses propres intérêts de
son propre avenir
et de ce point de vue là il ya rien à
dire mais on pourrait lui demander de
participer à une volonté collective et
c'est sous cet angle que je place la
question de la localisation des
activités de la reconquête de la baille
productif français
pour moi la responsabilité de l'étain
est là l'état doit être le fédérateur
l'entraîneur le il doit motiver et
passer devant leurs responsabilités les
différents acteurs autrement nous n'y
arriverons pas mais il se trouve que
aujourd'hui nous avons des chances qui
n'était pas ouverte aux années
précédentes et qui ne seront peut-être
plus ouverte après on a le sentiment
j'ai le sentiment que
on peut pour une fois sauté dans le
train
pourquoi parce que si je repense à
l'appareil productif
on est devant une mutation technologique
massive et majeur avant l'élément
déterminant c'était la main d'oeuvre et
le coût de la main d'oeuvre et à ce
moment là on vous disait mais vous voyez
bien monsieur ballon qu'on peut pas
s'opposer à la chine au vietnam à des à
des coûts de main d'oeuvre qui sont
telles que 30% de ce que nous avons à
déployer peut-être même mois et
peut-être discours sortent pas ceci est
en train de changer
parce que les modes de production
connaissent leur grande révolution avec
la robotique la les algorithmes les
dates aller quand qui a vu fonctionner
dans le monde industriel les imprimantes
3d de pointe qui produisent en quelques
heures et parfois fraction d'heure des
pièces qui avant demander des jours et
des jours d'usinage si on a vu ça on
comprend que quelque chose est en train
de changer et il se trouve que nous
sommes on pointe nous france dans ces
domaines là dans les domaines notamment
des algorithmes il ya une chaire au
collège de france d'algorithmique y est
observée comme un des lieux les plus les
plus avancés du monde sur ces sujets là
des compétences de boîte
je mets une note en bas de page nous
devons nous inquiéter d'autant plus de
l'effondrement du niveau des élèves en
mathématiques et ça aussi
si on est placé devant nos
responsabilités ce sujet est évidemment
un sujet majeur donc une grande mutation
technologique dans le domaine de la
production qui s'accompagne d'une
disponibilité quasi miraculeuse des
moyens d'investissement à des taux qui
dans aucune génération n'a eu l'exemple
si on met en face ces deux fenêtres
d'opportunités alors nous avons
peut-être quelque chose à à penser et à
dire et l'état le rôle de l'état peut
s'en trouver facilité voilà pour
répondre à votre question
madame de ces drac vous avez très
justement pointé la question des
panneaux photovoltaïques et de la
production des cellules photovoltaïques
et je l'avais dit dans mon introduction
la question là lauriane les cellules
photovoltaïques au silicium sont enfin
doivent nous placer devant deux éléments
d analyse
le premier de ces éléments sait d'où
vient l'énergie qui permet de produire
les cellules photovoltaïques au silicium
c'est-à-dire de fondre le silicium je
les dis et jancovici je crois la dis
devant vous en tout cas devant le sénat
je sais pas dans quelle organisation
cissé de l'électricité produite à partir
de charbon jamais la production
photovoltaïque ne remboursera l'émission
de gaz à effet de serre qui a permis de
produire les cellules 30 ans ça suffit
pas pour rembourser cet investissement
là mais si c'est une électricité
décarbonée alors on a là la possibilité
en effet de 2,2 d'aider puissamment au
bilan j'ouvre une fenêtre pas de rêves
d'avenir
il y actuellement des recherches qui
sont conduites autour du photovoltaïque
organique dont le bilan carbone est lui
extrêmement différents le bilan des
cellules photovoltaïques au silicium on
dit habituellement que ses 20 ans pour
rembourser la quantité de l'énergie
nécessaire à la production de la cellule
là c'est 20 jours et encore certains
disent même sept jours sont des cellules
qui ont moins de rendement mais qui ont
l'avantagé de pouvoir produire de
l'électricité même à l'ombre sur
n'importe quel façade il il guettait
prennent les photons c'est une
production électrique et ça coûte à
beaucoup moins cher et en production et
en pause
ça aussi c'est une voix ceci simplement
pour dire que moi je pense que que le
génie humain va pas s'arrêter
aujourd'hui et je je
je pense qu'une société qui retrouverait
la confiance dans sa capacité à innover
à créer à trouver à chercher alors on
aurait là quelque chose de deux d'une
réconciliation avec notre avenir
et voilà pourquoi j'adhère à votre
vision de filières sur ce sujet là en
particulier
j'imagine que vous aviez un objet précis
en tête
il ya en effet aujourd'hui des
relocalisations de production et on est
allé travailler avec le cea sur ce sujet
des relocalisations de production tout à
fait intéressantes notamment en
rendement de ces cellules avec des gains
de rendement de 15 à 20% et c'est c'est
évidemment très très important sans
compter la filière du recyclage et
j'adhère à ce que vous dites c'est aussi
c'est vrai d'ailleurs aussi pour les
batteries parce que le les recherches
sur les batteries elles se heurtent à la
question du recyclage des batteries
ce qui est d'ailleurs philosophiquement
intéressant parce qu'on voit le que le
que la grande idée du cycle des cycles
est une idée réelle
enfin qui se vérifie dans la réalité
monsieur médevielle enfin j'ai dit que
j'adorais à votre appel à l'humilité
alors je suis pas sûr qu'il soit de la
compétence du plan de deux réformes et
l'étiquetage du vin mais après tout
pourquoi pas parce que le parce que la
recherche de l'étiquetage standard
identifiables par les consommateurs
étrangers
ces présents depuis très longtemps dans
la réflexion de la viticulture et
pourquoi ça n'a pas avancé
ça c'est vous qui le savez mieux que moi
j'en ai une petite idée c'est que il
s'agit d'accepter des révolutions
internes
mais ce que je crois c'est qu'on
pourrait faire avancer ses réflexions en
même temps que la défense de notre
patrimoine de château de propriété de
d'acteurs individuelle et donc pour moi
c'est en effet deux types de réflexion
ouverte qui nous permettront d'améliorer
notre appareil productif et notre place
en commerce extérieur ce que c'est vrai
que la plupart de nos vins et de nos
châteaux y compris le jurançon qui est
comme dirait madame mariage le meilleur
vin du monde
en tout cas dans son secteur
c'est assez difficile à identifier étant
donné la dimension des productions donc
donc je partage cette réflexion avec
vous je serais content de la partager
dans le futur merci encore cette
question je vous demanderai des tasses
et boeuf est ce qu on a encore deux
sujets après à a évoqué donc j'ai donné
la parole à monsieur gilles et merci
président monsieur le haut commissaire
pour planifier il faut notamment avoir
une administration agile efficaces
dotées de moyens adéquat
quelle est votre analyse sur le sujet ce
que vous ferez justement des
propositions ou estimez-vous que c'est
hors champ aujourd'hui de votre mission
et puis également pour planifier il faut
pouvoir s'appuyer sur des acteurs de la
décentralisation des acteurs impliqués
et moteurs après une longue attente donc
il semblerait que la loi cadre des soit
de nouveau inscrite à l'agenda
pensez vous que cette loi sera une
réponse efficace pour permettre
d'impliquer donc l'ensemble des parties
prenantes dans une stratégie de
planification sur le plan national
et puis enfin bien sûr vous l'avez
souligné dans vos interventions
il faut une capacité budgétaire il faut
aussi une acceptabilité des grandes
orientations et donc quel est votre
calendrier sur ce sujet et dans le cadre
de ce quinquennat
parce qu'on est quand même sur un moment
qui est assez ramassé et si il faut que
les grandes lignes soient effectivement
validé je pense que nous sommes
plusieurs à souhaiter savoir qu'elle
serait effectivement le calendrier
quelque part de cristallisation des
positions je vous remercie
merci je mets ma parole à monsieur
pointereau oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le
le haut commissaire au plan finalement
vous succéder à la tête d'une mission
qui a existé déjà depuis fort longtemps
sous plusieurs formes et dans la
première a été créé en 1963 par le
général de gaulle et qui s'appelait la
datar et dont le délégué au plan était
monsieur olivier guichard et qui a été
un grands aménageurs du territoire est à
l'origine c'était deux étaient chargés
de rééquilibrer le territoire face aux
défis qui s'imposait à l'époque des
mutations économiques après de
l'après-guerre et afin qu'eux aussi que
les richesses économiques soient mieux
réparties sur le territoire pour
développer le monde rural également et
développer les infrastructures de
transport mais surtout avec une vision à
très long terme sur notre territoire
aujourd'hui on est en 2021 et finalement
on revient quelque part à la la case
départ et après cette crise sanitaire
économique social et bien que nous
vivons
là vous nous avez donné un certain
nombre de grandes lignes assez
généraliste sur lequel d'ailleurs nous
travaillons beaucoup déjà sûr dans notre
commission de ce que doit être
l'aménagement du territoire et un plan
pour l'avenir
mais concrètement quels sont les projets
sur lesquels vous travaillez pour la
désertification dans le monde rural mais
pas que pas que la des médecins aussi
sur la population qui quittent nos
villages sur la souveraineté de la
france en termes de réindustrialisation
on a plus de machines outils qui sont
fabriqués dans notre pays du retour de
nos chercheurs qui sont partis à
l'étranger de la relocalisation des
fabricants de médicaments qui sont
partis en asie comment on peut les faire
revenir chez nous et si on les fait
revenir chez nous il s'agit pas de les
mettre encore une fois là où il pleut
déjà là où il ya de la richesse parce
que il faut peut-être faire aussi de
l'aménagement du territoire et à
réinstaller ces localisations sur des
territoires qui sont en souffrance parce
que le ruissellement l'attend toujours
dans ces territoires là donc voilà quels
sont vos moyens
tout simplement pour agir concrètement
alors je dis pas financièrement parce
que j'ai par la pression vous avez un
gros budget à part pour fonctionner mais
quels sont vos concrètement vos votes
recoller concrètement votre pouvoir
d'agir auprès du président de la
république des différents ministères
parce que bon c'est ça qui nous
intéresse
merci g20 parole à monsieur houlgate
puis à madame préville l'un et monsieur
le président monsieur le commissaire
vous avez fait allusion tout à l'heure à
la première note que vous aviez produit
donc au dernier trimestre qui s'intitule
et si l'aco vide dur est donc cette
hypothèse se confirme d'une certaine
façon et il semble que donc la pandémie
avec
les différents variant elle va
s'installer donc durablement
bouleversant ainsi nos modes de vie nos
liens sociaux et nos rapports
économiques dans cette note vous
souligner qu'il d'une manière
structurelle pourrait se poser à terme
la question d'une économie nationale
remobilisés par l'action de la puissance
publique vous citez donc la prise en
charge du chômage partiel les prêts
garantis par l'état et vous dites que ça
présente les modalités de
l'interventionnisme économique comme
exemple de l'autorité nouvelles de ceux
qui seront chargés de l'action publique
alors ma question elle est très simple
comment passer d'un état stratège
inspiré par la lucidité et la
clairvoyance de la vision et de la
réflexion dont vous êtes aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs l'un des ddd témoin à un état
qui soit un état acteurs qui seraient
enracine dans l'action sur le long terme
vous avez fait allusion plan marshall au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale la
france et dans les décennies qui ont
suivi la france je dirais s'est dotée
d'une stratégie de filière alors en en
prenant appui à la fois sur des grands
organismes vous avez parlé du ceum on
pourrait dire l'inra l'inserm le cnes le
cnete le connexion et ainsi de suite
mais aussi sur des entreprises et est à
l'heure actuelle on sent que ces grands
organismes sont à la peine et que
d'autre part on a l'impression est
l'exemple de danone le site c'est que
nous entreprises
eh bien elles ont du mal à en didier
l'appétence pour ne pas dire l'avidité
des marchés financiers activistes sur le
court terme
donc comment essayer de ré enraciné donc
dans le long terme par la volonté de la
puissance de l'état
merci même préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le haut commissaire
alors par le passé nous avons connu
certains l'ont déjà évoqué des
planifications qui on est et vertueuse à
bien des égards puisque nous avons du
rail partout de l'électrification
maintenant ce qui se produisent ce sont
des initiatives des expérimentations
mais quid pour le pays et pour les
territoires qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de mettre en place ce toutes ces
choses là et ce qui se profile c'est
plutôt un pays avec un développement en
mosaïque voir en patchwork est là
vérité c'est que nous avons des
déséquilibres de plus en plus marqué sur
nos territoires ce qui d'ailleurs été
pointé par l'europe puisque nos régions
ont été déclassés de ce fait là pour
l'accession aux fonds européens
donc où est l'équité et est-ce que c'est
cela que nous voulons pour le
développement de notre pays et je vais
rebondir sur cette question là à propos
de l'énergie parce que ce qui se passe
actuellement dans le pays avec sur le
thème de l'énergie la production
d'électricité qui est déjà décarbonée ça
nous le savons mais puisque nous devons
fermer des centrales nucléaires et ce
qui se produit c'est le développement
ddd parc photovoltaïque des unités de
méthanisation
mais tout cela sans que cela ait
vraiment du sens et uniquement pour je
ne sais pas si c'est l'appât du gain en
tout cas pour quelque part faire de
l'argent or l'électricité n'était elle
pas un bien commun c'est un sujet
complexe qui est souvent caricaturée et
qui nécessiteraient je pense et c'est un
problème vraiment très important pour
notre avenir que davantage les français
soient sensibiliser informer et former
sur les tenants et aboutissants de
toutes les formes de production
d'électricité or ce n'est pas le cas et
donc on voit les gens foncé vers
certaines solutions sans même voir
exactement en quoi elle consiste donc
voilà je trouve que s'il ya vraiment un
problème important et très concrètement
il n'y a pas vraiment de planification
sont nos territoires sur l'installation
des parcs photovoltaïques des parcs
éoliens des unités de méthanisation ça
part dans tous les sens c'est quasi
anarchique et notamment dans mon
département qui est le lot
ensuite pour ce qui concerne la
réindustrialisation est ce qu'à un
moment donné il n'y a pas eu une espèce
de rôles assignés à la france au niveau
au centre de l'europe comme étant une
zone touristique et que nous avons à
pâtir de des choix qui ont été faits par
le passé et
vous avez parlé de cet appareil
productif qui est qu'il faudrait
réindustrialiser 1 qu'il faudrait
remettre en marche quelque part mais qui
est en déclin et pour l'instant il n'y a
pas d'arrêt à ce déclin alors comment
vous voyez vous comment vous voyez
d'endiguer ce phénomène est donc de de
permettre de regagner une place au sein
de l'europe et au sein de haut niveau
international de notre productivité
voilà je vous remercie merci même
préville monsieur dantec
oui merci monsieur le président c'est un
débat évidemment passionnant et un en
écoutant mais c'est le haut commissaire
et mes collègues et moi j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'on est toujours un peu
dans la nostalgie des trente glorieuses
du plan d'olivier guichard
même si sur les métropoles d'équilibré
il avait bien vu les choses mais c'est
justement le changement de paradigme
d'après guy sharks et qui est devant
nous et que finalement un nous
n'arrivons porte à sortir de nos deux
noms pesanteur et vous en avez donné
quand même plusieurs exemples quand on
parle je trouve avec beaucoup de
nostalgie de nos filières industrielles
des choix du général de gaulle défiance
des années 70 on oublie de dire qu'on a
totalement raté la filière informatique
etc le to7 de thomson est resté bien
seul et que là on s'est retrouvée
marginalisée qu'on a mis effectivement
toutes nos billes sur le nucléaire
industrie totalement marginal est de
plus en plus à l'échelle mondiale qui
sort aujourd'hui un kilowatt six fois
plus cher que le photovoltaïque et que
donc notre question est plus la capacité
de mutation rapide sur des secteurs qui
sont de fait à l'échelle mondiale des
secteurs d'impasse industriels et s'est
dit dans tous les rapports mondiaux sauf
en france
et finalement nous n'arrivons pas à
dépasser c'est ses pesanteurs et c'est
le cas aussi à d'autres niveaux et là je
suis d'accord avec vous c'était beaucoup
moins d'accord sur votre analyse du
photovoltaïque puisque c'est pathétique
c'est quand même 55 g
même avec du charbon chinois d'émissions
de co2 par kilo watt le nucléaire c'est
66 g mais si en plus on produit du
fauteuil de l'électricité effectivement
d origine non carbonées on baissera
encore le le bilan carbone met donc moi
mais je pense que notre question
aujourd'hui c'est comment nous sommes
capables de dépasser 1 la totalité des
lobbys et des pesanteurs de la société
française le lobby des médecins en est
un
je dirais le lobby des sénateurs peut en
être un parce que vous avez insisté sur
les intercommunalités moquera
de l'espace démocratique et pour les
régions on a les mêmes difficultés
donc on a des pesanteurs à différents
niveaux la haute administration nous des
fois d'autres lobbys et comment en tant
que co commissaire avec votre petite
équipe vous pouvez participer de sortir
de ses pesanteurs qui fondent la société
que la france est effectivement
aujourd'hui n'est pas dans une dynamique
très positive à l'échelle mondiale et je
le précise par deux questions 1 derrière
très courte
c'est la première sur le crt e et la c1
ça peut être un peu chez vous les
contrats de relancer transition
énergétique à l'échelle territoriale
moi je suis convaincu aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui remonte de tous les territoires
qu'on est en train de gaspiller l'argent
on est en train de gaspiller de l'argent
pour des raisons y compris de calendrier
électoral de vouloir dépenser tout de
suite relancer tout de suite et donc on
prend des projets qui sont mal mûri et
qui ne tape qu'un certain nombre de
filières qui sont pas les filières les
plus en difficulté aujourd'hui notamment
si on fait de la voirie ont fait des
choses sur lequel par ailleurs on n'a
pas de vraie crise c'est pas là que la
crise liée aux que vides et on n'a pas
de stratégie territoriale renforcée par
le crt eux donc je pense que là on est
en train de dépenser beaucoup d'argent
alors qu'il fallait plutôt le garder
dans la durée premier point est le
deuxième point qui m'a étonné c'est que
vous avez pas peut parler de l'europe
or les filières industrielles elles ne
sont plus à l'échelle nationale elles
sont obligatoirement à l'échelle
européenne et cette intégration
économique européenne
et quant à la grande différence par
rapport aux trente glorieuses finalement
vous l'avez très très peu évoquée dans
vos premières interventions messieurs
fernique
messieurs gold merci monsieur le
président monsieur le commissaire en a
mis en avant ce matin un certain nombre
de grands enjeux non à parler
d'alimentation on a parlé d'énergie on a
parlé de mobilité on a parlé de
numérique
on a parlé de santé droit qu'à un autre
enjeu de taille aussi sur le moyen et
sur le long terme qu'il faut pas
occulter c'est la gestion la
préservation de la ressource en eau avec
la multiplicité des usages et et
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
mon intervention c'est pas une question
mais simplement je voulais vraiment
mettre l'accent ce matin sur un sujet
qui me semble essentielle à court moyen
et long terme et qui peut pas être
simplement pas être occultée merci
monsieur calvet monsieur le commissaire
d'abord merci de la respiration que vous
nous avez offerte moi il y avait un
moment j'étais à l'époque à l'udf autant
que le dire nous avions des réflexions
et nous avions un peu de prospective et
je les fais pour ma part ma communauté
urbaine à l'époque à perpignan un projet
de territoire réflexion et ce qui est et
ce qu'il ce qui m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est que l'état et j'ai participé a pu
avec plusieurs mandats ici à l'assemblée
finalement à l'abandon du territoire et
l'état n'a plus joué ce rôle stratégique
depuis des années je ne vais pas revenir
comme certains l'ont dit à la mission
racine qui nous concerne est à perpignan
mais je voulais vous interroger ce matin
très simplement sur le tourisme et sur
la même pér hâtive nécessité d'aider à
la requalification de l'hébergement dans
l'ensemble de notre tourisme dans
l'ensemble de notre territoire rural
notamment que j'aille dans mes pyrénées
et du côté du côté de font romeu que
j'aille à lourdes les fois quand je vois
les hôtels quand je vois l'ensemble de
cet hébergement que j'aille à saint
nectaire
c'est notre parcours un peu partout et
bien pour des produits alimentaires
aussi bon et bien je vois un hébergement
qui n'est pas à la hauteur de ce que
nous devrions faire et là il ya un
immense enjeu et je suis désolé car par
exemple quand on vient de signer les
contrats de plan dire est à région dans
différentes dans différentes régions
nous n'avons jamais été associés à la
mise en oeuvre de ces contrats et nous
avons beaucoup de choses à dire
l'hébergement au touristique c'est ma
seule question mais ça n'aurait beaucoup
d'autres sur lesquels je pense qu'il ya
des réflexions à faire alors qu'à vous
parler de plan marshall sur le
commissaire peut être ça pourrait en
faire partie merci merci monsieur de vie
naze et monsieur chevrolet lycées et
merci monsieur le président merci sur le
haut commissaire merci d'ailleurs pour
votre exposé que j'ai trouvé moi très
pédagogique
j'étais très intéressé par la façon dont
vous a posé le problème énergétique sur
l'électricité et et renvoyant notre
avenir à l'électricité et puis vous avez
décliné les différents modes de produire
de l'électricité et qui quelque part
arrive à la solution dire que tout
compte fait les centrales nucléaires
c'est aussi une solution la joie et ou
soulever un autre problème vivent pas
très loin la centrale du bugey
ça n'est pas sa prolongation qui me pose
problème c'est que le changement
climatique fait que l'eau du rhône à
l'âme on arrive plus chaude que par le
passé aaron centrales nucléaires elle
doit être refroidie donc question
comment on fait demain et quand on
intègre aussi cette problématique
est-ce que la solution énergétique de
nos sociétés c'est l'électricité
oui c'est une question importante
dernier intervenant monsieur chevrollier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
haut commissaire nous avait parlé de
réenraciner le long terme dans la
politique française
c'est effectivement important d'avoir
une vision long terme dans une période
où on est plutôt dans la culture de
l'instant et la vision court termiste
des choses et donc c'est un vaste
programme qui vous nous proposez et ces
dernières années ces dernières décennies
a quand même eu sur un certain nombre de
sujets une politique de l'essuie glace
et sur les sujets majeurs que notre
émission traite que ce soit l'adaptation
au changement climatique la préservation
et la reconquête de la biodiversité
effectivement il faut avoir une vision
long terme mais j'aurais vous interroger
sur un point que vous avez abordé
uniquement par rapport aux taux
d'intérêt c'est le sujet de la dette qui
est un sujet qui vous intéresse depuis
longtemps déjà en 2002 vous en aviez
parlé et c'est un sujet qui nous
préoccupe façon aussi très importante
aujourd'hui quand on voit le notre
niveau d'endettement à 120 % et donc ses
capacités d'action de notre pays pour
pour agir donc vos réflexions sur le
sujet et à deuxième point sur vous avait
parlé de l'organisation territoriale
mais vous n'avez pas parler d'eux
du poids de la technocratie française et
quelles réflexions sur cette capacité de
nos élites sont importantes pour le pays
mais qu'elle s'adapte pour permettre
justement d'avoir une vision et un
avenir prospère pour votre pays merci
merci monsieur le haut commissaire à ces
quelques questions très complète
je salue l'art de monsieur chevrollier
de me prendre par les sentiments parce
que il m'interroge sur la dette et sur
la technocratie et en effet ce sont sont
des sujets sur lesquels depuis longtemps
je réussis de vous répondre tout de
suite puisque votre question vient
d'être posée je reprendrai ensuite
monsieur le président avec votre
permission dont dans l'ordre en effet
j'ai consacré une grande partie de mon
engagement public a essayé de faire
naître l'attention des citoyens de
l'opinion publique sur les déficits et
la dette
j'ai même conduit les campagnes vous
l'avez rappelé électorale sur ce sujet
alors qu'est-ce qui quel était le socle
de la réflexion et casque qui est en
train de changer
et vous avez un compatriote mayennais
qui qui s'occupe aussi du sujet et je
j'ai été auditionnée sur sur les
orientations que je portais sur ce sujet
par jean arthuis
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient profondément
choquant pour moi dans la manière dont
nous étions résignés et complice en face
de la constitution inde une dette trop
importante c'est que cette d'être là
elles étaient des voiliers il y a des
dettes juste normal intéressante
dont il faut défendre le principe par
exemple c'est le cas des dettes consacré
à l'investissement de long terme
quand vous allez construire une
université une autoroute une voie ferrée
à un réseau de satellites météo
ce sont des réalisations qui seront
utilisés par les générations à venir
il est donc normal qu'elles prennent une
partie de cette charge
c'est la même chose quand on construit
une maison pour sa famille en emprunter
c'est une dette légitime puisque mais ce
qui est profondément anormal c'est qu'on
se soit endetté sans limite quasiment
pour les charges courantes d'une société
de l'état il est pour moi pas normal que
hollande est qu'on met à la charge des
générations futures
les retraites que l'on paie aux
pensionnés actuelle c'est un supporter
il est totalement anormal qu'on met à la
charge des générations à venir
le remboursement de nos feuilles de sécu
actuel ce qui est fonctionnement courant
ne devrait pas devoir faire appel à la
dette
alors j'ai été ministre de l'éducation
pendant de nombreuses années
je connais très bien les débats sur ce
sujet
on peut dire que l'éducation c'est un
investissement
après il ya comme ça des des habiletés
de réflexion mais le front le le simple
le fondamental de cette réflexion
devrait être s'endetter pour investir
oui s'endetter pour les charges
courantes non que devons être d'une
certaine manière une règle d'or
vous aurez observé qu'on s'est pas
endetté pour investir jamais depuis les
20 dernières années très très peu et
c'est là que je suis moi profondément
choqué et je maintiens que le combat que
j'ai conduit avec un certain nombre
d'entre nous à cette époque était un
combat absolument fondée en justice et
en équité au travers des générations
alors quelque chose a profondément
changé je vous réponds précisément sur
la dette qu vide qu'est ce qui a changé
nous avons la chance parce qu'on a fait
les bons choix d'être sous la protection
tout cas sous le soutien d'une des
grandes banques centrales de la planète
très souvent je me dis mais où en
serions nous si nous avions voté non au
moment de ce référendum crucial de
maastricht
je pense qu'on serait beaucoup moins
bien de ce point de vue là les banques
centrales la banque centrale américaine
au premier chef la banque centrale
européenne avec mario draghi christine
lagarde etc ont fait le choix de
[Musique]
proposer une politique monétaire qui
permettait de soutenir l'activité du
pays et l'emploi l'activité de leur zone
et l'emploi et ça a été à mon sens une
politique bienvenus et ils sont pas
allés par quatre chemins le gouvernement
américain la banque centrale américaine
qui ont une grande différence avec la
banque centrale française européenne
la grande différence c'est que dans les
compétences dans la mission de la banque
centrale européenne il n'y a que la
stabilité des prix dans la mission de la
banque centrale américaine la federal
leurs réserves il y à la stabilité des
prix et le plein emploi est aussi une
politique de taux mesuré mais si vous
mettez l'instabilité et le plein emploi
la politique et pas tout à fait la même
donc là l'un fédéral réserve est allé
dans ce sens est en train dans notre
ignorance de faire des choix qui sont
des choix extrêmement lourd pour
l'avenir puisque le président biden a
annoncé qu'il allait mettre 1900
milliards de soutien et ils ont mis
aussi une somme du même ordre l'année
dernière 2020 2021
c'est près de 3500 à 4000 milliards qui
auront été mis sur la table c'est à dire
quelque chose comme 20 % du pib
américain sur deux ans et donc quand
j'appelle à un plan marshall de soutien
quand je prends la liberté d'appeler à
un prix hommage à l' de soutien je
compare ça avec les dépenses budgétaires
américaines c'est les banques centrales
permettent aujourd'hui on le sait bien
aujourd'hui d'emprunter à 0 % et même
assez souvent -2 0%
c'est vrai pour nos collectivités
locales aussi on vient de se contracter
dans ma dans ma ville et dans
l'agglomération dont je suis responsable
des emprunts à 0,38 % pour des sommes
considérables à mon sens c'est une
chance dont aucune des générations
précédentes da bénéficier et si c'est
pour de l'investissement
alors c'est sain premier aspect deuxième
aspect des mutations de nous devons
prendre en compte les dépenses qui ont
été consentis pour lutter contre
l'épidémie et ses suites sont des
dépenses que j'assimile mois des
dépenses de guerre lorsqu'une guerre
vous tombe tombe sur le destin de la
nation que sa survie est menacée
by ap haye a rien d'autre à faire que
acheter des avions des blagues et des
drones des est
et à soutenir la constitution d'unités
pour pour mener le combat parce que
c'est la survie de la nation qui est en
jeu c'est ce qui s'est passé pour moi
avec
avec 7 avec cette épidémie non pas comme
certains le disent que le virus c'est un
ennemi militaire c'est pas ça la
question
la question c'est qu'on était devant une
interrogation sur la survie de la nation
et de son modèle
à quoi s'ajoute le plan de reconquête
nécessaires pour financer le contrat
social français voilà pourquoi j'ai
proposé ces trois étapes première étape
identifier les dépenses liées
précisément à ces deux objectifs et les
cantonais et je propose qu'on fasse ça
saoule au contrôle de la cour des
comptes
j'ai rencontré hier monsieur moscovici
je pense que la cour des comptes est
prête à faire ça pour quoi
pour pas que tout le monde considère que
ces dépenses sont prioritaires et
doivent être affectés aux mêmes
au même coffre fort donc il faut de ce
point de vue là du sérieux et premières
étapes identifiées
cantonné deuxième étape je propose je ne
fais pas en lui en abordant cette
deuxième étape de la technique
financière et budgétaire
je sais très bien que pour un technicien
ce que je vais dire techniquement n'est
pas fondée mais politiquement salé
décrété que ces deux têtes la nécessaire
imposé par l'épidémie elles doivent
bénéficier d'un différé d'amortissement
elle ne pèseront pas pendant dix ans
alors tu point de vue technique de la
technique que financière je sais très
bien que c'est du refinancement de
dettes jeu même dans les pyrénées on
arrive à comprendre ça mais le le le
le fond de la mer c'est que la nation
dise voilà on a dix ans pour se
redresser
et cette dette ne pèsera pas pendant ce
temps là c'est un objectif de
mobilisation civique et ensuite allongé
la maturité de la dette pour que son
remboursement ne pèse pas trop vous
verrez là que je ne me range pas parmi
ceux qui demandent qu'on efface cette
dette
je pense qu'il n'y aurait pas de pire
risque que celui là parce que c'est très
simple à partir du moment où vous dites
que vous ne rembourserait pas plus
personne ne nous prêtera jamais or la
france à la différence de tous ses
voisins n'est pas un pays en excédent
primaire ses voisins pourraient la
limite dire on rembourse plus rien il
arriverait si la situation ne se
détériorait pas à vivre nous ne
pourrions pas nous france
nous sommes obligés d'avoir pendant un
certain temps le temps du redressement
recours à l'emprunt ce qui est
d'ailleurs une des manifestations de la
faiblesse que nous avons accepté au
travers du temps et contre laquelle je
me suis battue en effet alors ça c'est
le premier point pardon d'avoir été long
mais comme j'ai fait des propositions
sur ce sujet ensuite vous l'avez pris
par les sentiments en parlant de la
technocratie française je veux dire
trois choses très simples la première la
logique administrative c'est une logique
de prolifération continue
[Musique]
l'administration créer de
l'administration si vous avez le temps
je vous recommanderais volontiers la
lecture d'un d'un grand sociologue des
organisations anglais qui est un pur
génie qui s'appelle parkinson le livre
s'appelle les lois de parkinson
je vous encourage parce que c'est un un
monument d'humour et de justesse sur la
prolifération administrative
le principe est simple une
administration elle est obligée de
travailler pour justifier son existence
et donc elles s'intègrent et du travail
et ya jamais de services suffisants pour
y faire face
alors pardon de ce salaire de d'une
notation légère c'est une notation
extrêmement lourdes et quiconque a
gouverné y compris les collectivités
locales
sans parler de de la plus grande
administration du monde qui est
l'éducation nationale se fait une idée
de ce sujet ça c'est le premier sujet
deuxième sujet une des faiblesses ses
l'endogamie le même moule
or l'endogamie où que ce soit dans le
vivant elle produit des affaiblissements
et le modèle de pensée jeu je pense que
c'est une idée assez présentes à
l'esprit du président de la république
il a évoqué plusieurs fois et sur
laquelle il a fait une partie de sa
campagne
c'est qu'il faut sortir du moule et
troisième sujet je m'arrêterai là c'est
que tout ça pose un problème social
extrêmement lourd un problème de
d'incompréhension entre le prétendu haut
de la pyramide est la base de la
pyramide sociale qui fait qu' on ne
parle plus la même langue que les règles
les contrôles les freins qui sont ceux
de l'administration qui sont ceux
produits par l'administration où il ya
des gens très bien ce ça rien à voir
s'impose à l'action publique notamment
locales et aussi à l'action économique
ou des créateurs ou des inventeurs ou
des innovateurs et sont plus souvent
bloquante que soutient et c'est 3 si
vous mettez ensemble ces trois
considérations notamment le social qui
fait que désormais en aide dans un
recrutement qui est assez socialement
réservé à ceux qui grosso modo on les
codes et aux autres pas cette question
là à mon sens pose en effet une question
de l'organisation de notre action
publique administrative en france par
don de parler crûment mais c'est
absolument ce que je ressens et vous
voyez que de ce point de vue là en effet
je n'ai pas changé de conviction alors
je vais répondre rapidement pardon mais
comme vous m'avez pris sur deux sujets
de prédilection mais l'administration
monsieur gilles et m'a interrogé oui oui
où est-il monsieur gilles est donc c'est
pas entendu tous venez de le voir et
probablement faudra-t-il en effet que
nous consacrions des travaux à ce sujet
assez assez vite je ne sais pas du tout
hors champ si on fait le bilan des
faiblesses de notre pays
il ya là à mon sens une question en
effet sur la loi 4d j'espère qu'elle va
venir
c'est en tout cas c'est ce que sa
ministre espère
que vous connaissez bien et puis qu'à
l'entrée dans le quinquennat
nous y sommes le nous allons entrer dans
l'année cruciale pour le quinquennat
naturellement et pour sam conclusion je
n'ai qu'une ambition c'est que ces idées
figurent dans le débat je prétends pas
du tout même si vous n'y avez poussé les
uns ou les autres à dire qu'on va
décider
sur tous ces sujets de ce qu'on va faire
ça c'est la sphère du gouvernement et je
prend grand soin de ne pas entrer en
conflit ou en concurrence ou en quoi que
ce soit avec le gouvernement c'est
l'exécutif à ses responsabilités et nous
nous sommes par la dimension
naturellement le sans comparaison
possible avec un gouvernement une
administration millions de
fonctionnaires et tout ça mais nous
pouvons semer des idées peut-être un
jour pousser jusqu'à leur réalisation
voilà pour le pour le calendrier
monsieur point trop où est il
j'aimais beaucoup les richards mais
c'est vrai que ce que monsieur dantec a
dit est assez juste ce nous avons changé
d'époque
nous étions un pays qui pouvait décider
pour lui même à l'intérieur de ses
propres frontières d'un certain nombre
de choses mais le monde ne permet plus
de décider seulement à l'intérieur de
ses propres frontières
il ya un mot que vous avez utilisé qui
est juste c'est vous avez dit comment
comptez vous agir auprès du président de
la république du gouvernement c'est
exactement ma mission telle que je la
conçois c'est-à-dire fait ressortir des
problématiques et des lignes de force et
les partager avec les décideurs de
premier rang on est plutôt
du côté de ceux qui avertissent de ceux
qui cherchent à faire entrer des idées
dans l'atmosphère de la décision
publique
et c'est une tâche absolument précieuse
alors vous avez dit que ça commençait
avec la datar et olivier guichard non ça
commence avec jean monnet qui a été
installé par le général de gaulle
précisément pour faire ça et qui ensuite
a pris le plan marshall comme comme
objet de comme objet de planification
mais c'est le général de gaulle qui a
voulu ça il le dit à toutes les pages de
ses mémoires tout le temps il dit ça ça
doit être la sphère de cette réflexion
de long terme que porte que porte le
plan donc voilà monsieur point trop
comment relocaliser les chercheurs on
consacrera une étude à ce sujet de la
recherche et de son organisation
ce qui me frappe c'est là la
parcellisation de l'organisation de la
recherche en france je j'ai essayé de
faire la cartographie de la recherche en
virologie ya dix ou onze organismes
différents qui accueille des chercheur
en virologie
et ouais le rôle fédérateur tille
soutien aide articule c'est ce qui
manque le plus le plus en france donc il
ya de ce point de vue là un travail
d'organisation
il ya une question très simple pourquoi
les chercheurs que nous avons éduqué
formé promu
porté au niveau international pourquoi
par le tea party utile pour deux raisons
la première on leur donne des moyens de
travailler et la deuxième il ya une
reconnaissance matérielle que la france
rebelles à leur offrir
et si on veut pas regarder ça en face
alors il nous reste les yeux pour
pleurer et a constaté que tu est
l'inventeur de vaccins a été formé en
france le patron de moderna et français
le et si nous les avons laissé partir
c'est que nous les avons fait partir et
tout le reste est littérature et donc
malgré mes goûts personnels je ne m'y
associerais pas voilà monsieur
pointereau monsieur houlgate
où est-il sur quatre pardon vous avez
posé une question absolument centrale
j'ai esquissé une réponse mais je vais
la reprendre avec vous c'est pas très
bien ce que veut dire état stratège
alors je sais très bien où je compte
suis très préoccupé par les questions de
stratégie depuis longtemps mais la
question que vous posez c'est si vous
avez une stratégie comment vous la fait
appliquer et il n'est pas vrai que
l'état tout seul puisse l'état doit être
gelée dit dans mon introduction
fédérateur il faut qu'il prenne en
compte la diversité de ceux qui vont
participer à la stratégie définie
c'est à dire toutes les formes de
puissance publique et les acteurs
individuels et les entreprises les
collectivités locales le
l'administration et l'état plus les
entreprises plus par exemple les
innovations et les recherches privées et
il faut il a pour mission de définir
suffisamment clairement et de faire
participer tous ces acteurs à cette
stratégie là depuis combien de temps ça
n'a pas été fait en france presque un
demi-siècle
parce que c'était l'idée que le général
de gaulle se faisait et il avait réussi
à faire partager songer aux grands
programmes et je ne fais pas du retour
en arrière je regarde pas le rétroviseur
et les grands programmes
ils datent tous deux plus de 50 ans et
depuis on a été prisonnier d'une
idéologie qui voulait que ou vont
l'intérêt général ne soit pas autre
chose que la somme des intérêts
particuliers
or je crois que c'est faux et on le
constate aujourd'hui l'intérêt général
peut être définies indépendamment même
si c'est en liaison avec les intérêts
particuliers
et ça c'est le rôle de l'état et
pardonnez moi de le dire devant vous
c'est le rôle des responsables
politiques les responsables politiques
parlementaires exécutif
leur mission c'est celle là de faire
partager à la communauté nationale début
qu'elle ne saurait pas formulé s'il n'y
avait pas une vie démocratique c'est la
raison pour laquelle comme vous l'avez
compris je suis pas très favorable au
tirage au sort parce que
faire dépendre des décisions
vous voyez je suis très minoritaire
j'accepte faire dépendre des décisions
d'intérêt public de l'aléatoire sans
qu'on sache ni qui ni ce que pensent
ceux qui savaient pas progresser le
débat public ça fait pas progresser la
conscience et ça fait pas poser c'est la
responsabilité mais j'accepte d'être
contredit sur ce sur ce sujet et donc
oui les grands organismes et oui les
entreprises ont quelque chose à voir
dans ce sujet c'est la responsabilité de
l'état de les fédérer
madame préville oui madame préville
est-ce que l'électricité peut être
considérée comme un bien commun oui le
l'immense organisation de production de
l'électricité et de son transport c'est
en effet un bien commun après comment on
organise le bien commun et puis avoir dû
du public et du privé dans le bien
commun les zones sont à délimiter et je
vous suis reconnaissant de ne pas
m'avoir interrogé sur le plan hercules
et donc et tanks mais vous avez
complètement raison de dire que il y a
là une tâche d'éducation civique très
importante
et d'éducation tout cours d'éducation
populaire tout coup qu'on a laissé
tomber et c'était à mon sens une grave
erreur alors j'ai pas d'accord avec vous
sur le fait qu' il y aurait eu une
décision mystérieuse prise quelque part
que la france devrait être une réserve
touristique que empathie pas aux autres
enjeux je ne le crois pas je crois pas
qui est une main noire quelque part mais
vous serez d'accord avec moi et moi avec
vous sur cette formulation mais nous
avons laissé faire
dont nous l'avons accepté et encore une
fois pour avoir mené des combats
acharnés sur ce sujet du produire en
france et en europe
je maintiens que oui on le savait mais
on a laissé faire c'était plus facile et
peut-être aussi le la communauté
d'intimité entre l'état et les grandes
entreprises à participer à ça à ce qui
est une résignation alors comment
arrêter le déclin par le débat public et
je ne connais pas d'autres moyens par la
prise de conscience et le partage avec
l'opinion publique de la conscience de
l'urgence de la situation devant
laquelle nous nous trouvons et du risque
mortel qu'il y assure notre modèle de
société si on veut si si on ne relève
pas ces défis là monsieur dantec
je vais répondre tout de suite à la
question pourquoi vous ne vous n'avez
pas parlé de l'europe dans ce sujet je
vous dire le fond de ce que je pense
vous serez libre de partager mon
sentiment
parce que la question n'est pas
européenne elle est française
les faiblesses que je décris la prise de
conscience nécessaire
la mobilisation que je voulais que je
voudrais voir naître ça se joue pas à
bruxelles
ça se joue chez nous dans chacun de nos
communes je dirais dans chacune de nos
réunions de famille
si on ne se rend pas compte de la menace
qui pèse sur nous était défis que cela
nous impose alors on va perdre la
bataille et on retrouvera des réflexions
de l'avant guerre de 40 l'étrange
défaite
faut pas chercher très loin pour que
cette étrange défaite elle trouve des
échos dans la situation actuelle du pays
et je suis
aussi profondément européen que vous
pouvez l'imaginer mais c'est chez nous
que ça se joue et notre place en europe
c'est chez nous qu'elle se joue et nulle
part ailleurs
et donc je suis d'accord avec vous pour
dire que ça ne doit pas se regarder dans
le rétroviseur ce que nous faisons c'est
faire face à des temps nouveaux
en sachant que les temps toujours été
nouveau depuis que le temps étant il est
nouveau mais y'a vous voyez une espèce
de deux cyclos dynamique
ce cd cycle mais qui avance et donc on
se il n'est pas étonnant qu'on se
retrouve avec des problèmes de l'après
guerre parce que d'une certaine manière
nous avons accepté un
un déclassement comme celui de la guerre
à imposer à la france je parle de l'aga
de 40 la guerre de 14 est un drame
européen qui que nous n'avons pas fini
de payer alors sur les contrats de
relance de transition écologique que de
transition énergétique
j'suis pas forcément d accord avec vous
voilà je pense qu'on fait des choses
dans la précipitation ce qu'elles sont
totalement fondée en réflexion j'en suis
pas certain mais où sont les lieux de
réflexion et où sont les lieux de
réflexion dont on tienne compte
je le répète je ne lis jamais vous vos
études les études sorties des
commissions les rapports que vous
produisez sans me dire qu'est ce que ça
va devenir
et la réponse est là ce n'est pas
al avantage de notre démocratie
française
donc c'est pour manifester monsieur
dantec mon accord avec une grande partie
des choses que vous avez dit monsieur
gold ou est-il monsieur colts je peux
pas dire autre chose que vous avez
raison et que la ressource eau sa
gestion
sa gestion respectueuse de
l'environnement et en même temps lucide
et et prudente
je prends un exemple on a beaucoup parlé
d'énergie et d'énergies propres
moi j'ai la conviction qu'on n'est pas
au bout de nos ressources en
hydroélectricité et pour quelqu'un qui
qui vit au bord des gaves des pyrénées
je vois bien qu'il ya là de l'énergie
sans porter atteinte à l'environnement
mais ça impose qu'on accepte de sortir
des schémas préétablis qui dit on touche
plus jamais au cours d'un cours d'eau
c'est la régulation de la ressource en
eau des inondations en particulier et
c'est une énergie gratuite disponible
entièrement verte
peut-être ça nous oblige à imaginer en
hydroélectricité des parcours nous vous
rue peut-être ça nous oblige à nous
interroger sur les décisions qui vont
être prises en matière
d'hydroélectricité
dans les rapports entre le l'europe et
la france entre l'union européenne et la
france
donc vous avez complètement raison
[Musique]
l'histoire de l'humanité songez à
l'egypte c'est l'histoire de la gestion
de l'eau et donc notre mission
historique comme génération elle n'est
pas différente de celle des générations
qui nous ont depuis si longtemps précédé
donc je suis d'accord avec vous et je
suis d'accord aussi pour qu'on y
travaille si ça vous intéresse
monsieur calvet si l'udf traité si bien
c'est qu'elle devait avoir un bon
secrétaire général est un bon président
un seul l'époque que vous évoquez tant
que je ne peux que vous donner raison
mais nous ne parlons pas politique ni
vous ni moi je suis d'accord pour dire
que la question de l'hébergement
touristique est une question de
reconquête de notre appareil productif
ce que dans l'appareil productif via
l'industrie et à l'agriculture et la
pêche et ya les services et nous sommes
en effet un grand pays touristique une
quasi premier au monde
et parfois on a l'impression que nos
services sont pas tout à fait à la
hauteur c'est donc une question de de
reconquête celle là aussi et peut-être
dans des sauts mesurés du plan marshall
que j'évoque parce que si nous c'est
vrai pour le tourisme que pour le reste
si nous ne réinvestissent ont pas au
moment critique où nous sommes
ça sera pas une victoire et je crois que
ça sera un échec assez lourd parce que
les nos concurrents et voisins ont les
moyens de l'investissement ils ont su se
créer les moyens de l'investissement et
donc il faut aussi se dire qu'ils vont
pas voir d'un oeil
totalement enthousiaste sauf que si la
france se développent leurs clients se
développeront élisions donc l'intérêt si
les états unis ont emporté le plan
marshall
c'est qu'ils savaient qu'ils auraient là
des clients et ils ont même obligé dans
un certain nombre de cas on parlait tout
à l'heure de machines-outils ceci n'est
pas très éloigné du sujet et enfin
monsieur devinettes
où est il passé oui la question du
refroidissement des centrales est une
question technique central les
ingénieurs sont pas tous d'accord sur le
sujet en tout cas ce que je lis moi il
ya des débats mais je suis d'accord avec
vous pour pour que ces débats soient à
suivre simplement votre dernière phrase
votre dernière interrogation qui était
de dire mais est-ce que l'électricité la
clé de l'énergie à venir alors monsieur
le sénateur faut vous dépêcher de faire
entendre cette raison parce que
aujourd'hui la totalité des réflexions
autour de l' usage de l'énergie
je parle pas de la production le lusage
de l'énergie ale ce centre autour de
l'art et électrification du chauffage
des logements et du parc automobile par
batterie par hydrogène ce sont deux
modalités différentes
parce que l'hydrogène offre plus de
chance pour l'avenir parce que le
recyclage des batteries est une question
extrêmement lourdes et le bilan carbone
des batteries aussi ce qui est pas tout
à fait le cas pour l'hydrogène mais
l'orientation générale aujourd'hui
peut-être
cette orientation générale peut-elle
être interrogé mais l'orientation
générale c'est droit vers l'électricité
comme énergie propre
encore faut-il qu'elle soit propre voilà
vous remercier de de la qualité de la
sympathie parfois de l'empathie de nos
échanges
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]